what's up guys welcome to IG likes now
this is a special episode because I am
not at my house I'm actually in New York
for the YouTube Music Awards and I'm
super excited they are the Sunday can
you guys just check out my Fox sweater
because I'm real excited about it so the
YouTube Music Awards happening on
November 3rd at 6 o'clock Eastern so you
guys can watch on youtube.com slash
YouTube most importantly until then you
guys can vote for your favorite artist
in any of the categories it's actually
pretty easy all you have to do is share
the official nominee video on G+ on
Twitter on Facebook in places that you
guys like to share your videos since
we're on the topic of music this video I
about I don't know like I'm actually
almost made me cry it's an emotional
baby crying because of the mothers it's
like the cutest thing ever and I don't
even like babies but I do like puppies
so here's some dogs singing
play that's the performance of a
lifetime
Bing
good girl I wanted some Tekken gaming
news I'm pretty excited because the
first sign of new consoles has arrived
at my doorstep I received my PlayStation
4 controller of which I proceeded to
destroy the unboxing bunch of other
people said that they have spotted some
games some controllers in the
playstation 4 camera in game stops so
guess what that means it's almost time
the ps4 will be out November 15th and
the Xbox one which I am super excited
about will be out on November 22nd so
basically you guys may never see me
again unless you're on my gaming channel
yes ahead we have a secret ban that we
start up we can't tell you about a
totally top secret right now
yeah it's top secret also big gaming
news Assassin's Creed Black Flag is now
out and I've actually just been watching
gameplay because I didn't travel with my
xbox on this trip so I'm excited to go
home and play but even more excited for
November 5th because as you guys already
know it's my favorite game Call of Duty
ghosts is coming out I can't go suit it
up first thing you probably should fix
my hair also should probably note that
it's Halloween today unless you're
watching this tomorrow it's probably not
Halloween so happy Halloween let me know
what you guys are gonna be for Halloween
send me some pics I was Batman in a
onesie so obviously I was very comfy
moving right along to I J book club I am
pretty excited because I downloaded
Melissa explains it all so back in the
day Melissa Joan Hart had a show called
Clarissa explains it all and I used to
be obsessed she now has a book out and
obviously I'm not gonna read it because
I'm going to have it be read to me with
my fantastic
audible let me know what book you guys
get using audible.com slash iJustine you
get a free book you get a free trial by
now you guys should probably know the
drill there's a link in the description
so I got to do is click it and it'll
take you to do the rest that's it for
this episode of IJ likes here from New
York stay tuned because I'm going to be
doing a lot of fun stuff this week with
YouTube and the YouTube Music Awards I
believe would be hosting the red carpet
with stylehaul so check them out on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram in
YouTube because they will probably be
posting videos
and photos before I will even get a
chance to let me know if you guys have
any questions that you would like me to
ask people on the red carpet if there's
a certain musician or certain youtuber
that she would like me to find to
interview leave in the comments I will
see you guys later
I gotta go do some some secret stuff
you